Donald Trump jr. takes no prisoners
during an appearance on the view
meanwhile the smart X administration
officials stay on the Trump train and
even more Democrats get ready to jump
into the presidential race as the odds
of the president's re-election increase
we will examine why the Teflon Don the
Teflon Don's
keep winning nikki Haley blows the
whistle on sabotage in president Trump's
cabinet
surveys show conservatives are hotter
and more dateable than liberals I've
been saying it for years and a young
Magga hat glad he wrote trolls MSNBC all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Dole show
[Music]
so much to get to the Don jr. clip on
the view is one of the most satisfying
things I have seen a network television
in my entire life I want to get to that
I especially want to get to the story
about how hot we all are but first I got
to thank our friends over at stamps.com
stamps.com
you know that the holiday season is upon
us this is going to change your life
stamps.com brings all of the services of
the US Postal Service right to your
computer that's whether you're a small
office sending invoices or you're an
online seller shipping out products
which is going to be increasing
dramatically soon or even if you're a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps.com can handle it all with
ease you simply use a computer to print
official US postage 24/7 never closed
you never a long line for any letter any
package any class of mail anywhere you
want to send I'm a millennial I like
things to be very convenient for me I do
not like to be inconvenienced at all I
want to do it all from my chair you can
do it with stamps calm once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
where you drop it in the mailbox it is
just that simple and unbelievably you
would expect to pay extra for this you
would expect to and I would be willing
to pay extra but with stamps calm you
actually get five cents off every
first-class stamp you actually get 40%
up to 40% off Priority Mail stamps calm
is a no-brainer saves you time saves you
money it is no wonder that over 700,000
small business has already used stamps
calm and we obviously daily wire love
stamps calm life is too short not to
take advantage of time-saving services
like stamps calm don't waste another
minute of your holiday season in the
post office this year sign up for stamps
calm no risk and you can use the promo
code normal skin to wles you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale now no long-term commitments no
contract stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Noel's ko wles stamps comm
intern old stamps calm never go to the
post office again Donald Trump jr.
Donald Trump Junior
just it was so sweet it was I don't even
know how to describe it so I will give
it no introduction other than to say the
view made a very very big mistake
inviting on Donald Trump jr. to promote
his new book triggered here is how the
interview began he's talking about
lowering the discourse to his level
which is horrible for this country even
if people are working we don't want to
have a country like that ok so I want it
to be clear here they started the fight
the view started the fight the way this
is being portrayed in the media is that
Donald Trump jr. came in there with guns
blazing just going out to lob bombs at
the hosts hostesses of the view that's
not what happened joy behar started it
and she said look I don't care if people
are working I don't care if the economy
is going great I don't care if consumer
confidence is very high I don't care if
all of that is so great the discourse
has been lowered in this country which
is the greatest example of a pot calling
kettle black I have ever seen in my life
Joy Behar a hostess of the view a show
that has almost single-handedly degraded
discourse in America I mean truly an
example of some of the worst discourse
in the American public sphere is is
hurling this insulted Trump and saying
your father has degraded discourse in
America this shows you a key fact about
Trump which I think a lot of Trump's
critics misunderstand especially as
critics on the right must understand
this what we're pointing out so much of
the time what is clear so much of the
time from the Trump era is not that
Donald Trump is the greatest guy that
ever lived it's not that Donald Trump is
the most eloquent guy or the greatest
president it isn't that it's that Trump
is better than his critics the lesson is
that the criticisms lobbed by Trump's
critics are actually more applicable to
the critics themselves you
this total explosion of self-awareness
because if you are a hostess on the view
accusing somebody else of degrading this
course you have lost the narrative so
joy behar starts the attack she says
you've degraded our discourse your
father's offensive and John Jr unloads
we're talking about bring a discourse
down joy
you've worn blackface Whoopi it wasn't
rape rape when he raped a child so let's
bring this up the blackface Leo she was
not in blackface sorry listen being
black I recognize blackface this I can
say so no apparently she doesn't because
Whoopi Goldberg very famously was
sitting and laughing at a dinner next to
her then-boyfriend
Ted Danson who was wearing actual
blackface by the way I'm not attacking
Whoopi Goldberg or Ted Danson for this
but clearly Whoopi Goldberg has a
history here with blackface and it's you
can't use that attack to assault or you
can't use the attack of offensiveness to
assault Donald Trump or Donald Trump jr.
or any of them and then meanwhile deny
that your friends and your co-hosts have
worn blackface and say it never happened
it's just gas lighting we saw it happen
we saw the photo of Ted Danson and by
the way we saw Joy Behar wearing
blackface in the 1970s and she didn't
just wear it we didn't just see the
photo she actually admitted to it on
television oh you know this picture no I
know
it was a Halloween party I went as a
beautiful African woman oh yes you ain't
black
you beat me em it is that is me you have
tanning lotion on a little my head
makeup that was a little bit better than
my hair a little bit makeup with a
little bit darker makeup was just a
little war dark makeup to go in a
costume as a black person but that's not
blackface because it's only blackface
when conservatives do it even though I
can't think of a time that conservatives
have done it because Justin Trudeau is
not a conservative Ralph Northam is not
a conservative Ted Danson's not a
conservative joy behar is not a
conservative I could go on and on and a
Billy Crystal's not a conservative when
he dressed like Sammy Davis jr. I mean
we we would spend the whole show talking
about left-wingers wearing blackface and
I'm not even attacking them for that I'm
pointing out the gas lighting because
Whoopi Goldberg and Joy Behar say
blackface is terrible you can't wear it
I never wore it
I've never approved of anybody wearing
it yes you did you did so maybe before
you start throwing stones at Donald
Trump for how offensive he is maybe just
take a look at before you accuse me take
a look at yourself so Don jr. flips the
script on the view this is a key of the
Trump era is that flipping the script
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander if the left is going to
attack us in a way that some deem unfair
Trump is going to attack them in that
way he's not going to unilaterally
disarm and apparently this trait applies
not just to the father but also to the
son you broke down this piece of ice
because I guess this is the fight you
want about your questioning my father's
character I simply said that when you're
talking about that your father's taken
more heat than anybody else that it's
not shot instead so she says this is the
fight you wanted Don jr. no it's not
they started the fight this is what the
left
always does to us say you you started it
you want the fight you're bringing that
no we don't you know when we when we go
to college campuses some of us
conservatives who go give speeches at
college campuses the the left which
becomes often by actually physically
violent becomes almost always disruptive
accuse us of starting the fight we're
not starting the fight we're giving
lectures at college campuses that's what
college campuses are for we're
exchanging different ideas on college
campuses that's what college campuses
are for the people who are causing the
disruption the people lobbying the
attacks the people who are becoming
sometimes violent they're the ones who
are starting and they're gaslighting us
and for so long conservatives were
cowered by this kind of behavior we'd
say oh gosh they're calling us they're
saying we're starting the fight on TV we
don't want to seem it because like the
TV's stacked against us so they're gonna
make us look bad and we don't want to
look bad and we're trying to appeal to
the people that the TV appeals to so
we're just gonna back down and let the
left run roughshod over the culture not
just on TV but in the movies not just in
the movies but on college campuses and
the thing that people love so much about
Trump even more than the mean tweets
even more than some of the policy
successes frankly is that he's fighting
back this is a trait that after Trump is
gone Trump is a unique figure in
American politics once he's gone you're
not gonna have candidates like him
anymore he's one of a kind okay an
American original but we can at least
learn this one lesson from Trump which
is just don't take it don't lie down and
take it even when you're invited into
the Lions Den on the view don't just lie
there and take it they start the fight
you finish the fight Don Jr then goes
nuclear at the end of this he's prompted
by a question from Abby Huntsman whom I
love when by the way when I am
criticizing hosts on the view just
assume that I'm not criticizing Abby
Huntsman who is a friend of mine for a
while and I like her very much however
my friendship with Abby does not excuse
the other women on the view if like Joy
Behar who were just absolute
destroying public discourse so Abbi
though Abby pushes back on Don jr. and
says your father is imperiling the
whistleblower your father is not
following the norms on the whistleblower
and it's important that we protect
whistleblowers and whistleblowers are
great and if you ever reveal the
identity of a whistleblower or otherwise
punish a whistleblower for blowing the
whistle you're really being a bad
whistleblowing sort of person Don jr.
flips the script even their rights
because I care about diplomacy in this
country I care about how we protect the
people when they see a wrongdoing that
they go through the proper political
channels and they are protected for
doing that so you can see that whatever
can result in the name has been out
there for five days that doesn't make it
right but nevertheless a Singh down a
whistleblower about all of the Epstein
stuff because those stories were killed
so if we're gonna have the conversation
about the average broke we stick to what
she asked in the question just because
if we start getting off
[Applause]
so you see what Whoopi does in there she
jumps in the minute that Don Jr answers
Abby's point Whoopi says no no we're not
talking about the epstein whistleblower
we're not talking about the people at
ABC News who leaked video to James
O'Keefe of our own hosts talking about
how ABC News killed the Epstein story
we're not talking about that kind of
whistleblower we're only talking about
the kind of whistleblower the hurts
Trump you can't talk about she says you
you've got to stay on topic Dunn jr. is
staying on topic he's saying hold on a
second you're casting aspersions on my
father for for what for saying that he
has a right to face his accuser all in
the name of the whistleblower meanwhile
your network that we are currently on is
chasing down whistleblowers for pointing
out actually corrupt behavior from this
network so corrupt that they're actually
ABC is working with CBS to chase down
this guy who leaked the footage of a
host telling the truth about how ABC
News killed the story about Jeffrey
Epstein who by the way did not kill
himself just that's sort of a sidebar he
flips the script entirely we should
learn this lesson all the time do not
accept the left premises you know even I
was I was having a debate it in
Nashville a politican with Clay Aiken I
was supposed to be having a debate with
the Democrat Chris on but it ended up
becoming a debate with the moderator
quote-unquote play akin and what Clay
Aiken kept trying to do was get me to
say the exact words that he wanted me to
say by by which he would get me to
accept his premises and look bad
so one thing he tried to get me to do is
he tried to push the same kind of hoax
about the Charlottesville rally that the
mainstream media pushed which is that
Donald Trump defended neo-nazis and
white supremacists in Charlottesville so
he wanted me to say that there aren't
there weren't very fine people on both
sides not very fine people on both sides
of the debate over taking that
historical monuments but specifically
the people who chanted Jews will not
replace us he wanted me to defend people
chanting Jews will not replace us and I
said clay what a stupid question what a
ridiculous question Nazis are bad I
think we all agree but he couldn't leave
it there because the choir
Ginny was asking me was more or less hey
Michael when did you stop beating your
wife either
anyway you answer that question you look
bad this is what the left always does
flip that script do not accept the
premises you don't owe them an answer
Don jr. doesn't owe an answer on
whistleblowers to the view on ABC ABC
owes an answer on whistleblowers to us
Don jr. doesn't owe an answer on
degrading American discourse to Joy
Behar Joy Behar owes an answer on
degrading American discourse to us don't
accept the premises don't accept this
ridiculous idea that you Oh people you
owe people on the left some kind of
answer on I don't know and little
children they were for a while they were
saying that the Trump administration was
imprisoning children which isn't true
these parents were sending their
children across the border illegally in
violation of the law and then they were
obviously were being detained in held in
custody you don't owe an answer to the
left on that the left kills million
babies a year the left is now supporting
injecting little children with hormones
to stop them from going through puberty
you don't owe an answer to them
Don Jr proofed it I love it I think
that's a key lesson of the Trump area
you can see how dishonest the people are
the website PolitiFact is actually now
lying about a video that we all saw with
our own eyes we'll get to that in a
second we'll get to what that means both
for the administration in 2020 and for
the Democrats running for president
because there's a lot of news on both
friends first I've got to thank our
friends over at policy genius it's very
important to have life insurance and you
can't just rely on your employer
provided life insurance especially if
you work at the Daily wire because I
don't know been put all this little
language in my life insurance policy
that seems to give them a few ways out I
don't know to properly provide for your
families you will need I on average this
is what people expect 10 times the life
insurance coverage that you get through
your job that means that your employer
life insurance is a leaving you
underinsured that is where policy genius
can help policy genius is the easiest
way to shop for a life insurance plan
that's not tied to
job in minutes you go you compare quotes
from the top insurers to find the best
price once you apply the policy genius
team will handle all of the paperwork
and all of the red tape this is very
important because I handle I hate
handling all of that the life insurance
you buy through policy genius stays with
you even if you leave your job and
policy genius doesn't just make it easy
to get life insurance that can also help
you find the right home they can help
you find the right auto insurance and we
help you find the right disability
insurance all of that as well it's just
an amazing tool one of the great
advantages of living in the 21st century
is that we have these sorts of tools
available to us to make opaque and
complicated things much simpler much
easier to do when you are looking at
your workplace benefits this month make
sure to double check your life insurance
options you know I mean let's say god
forbid the worst happened I wouldn't
want to leave sweet little ELISA in a
lurch you should not leave your family
allergic o2 policy genius.com get quotes
apply in minutes very important to do
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance I'll just show
you how dishonest these people are and
why Don jr. needs to go in there and go
nuclear
PolitiFact sent out this tweet quote a
Trump ad said Democratic presidential
candidates quote support giving illegal
immigrants free health care at our
expense we rated that mostly false now a
Florida GOP leader made a similar
statement it's still mostly false so
what PolitiFact an organization that
pretends that it exists to fact-check
politicians not biased at all not
partisan at all in reality it's just a
leftist website but they pretend to be
neutral they pretend to be objective
they say that the statement the
Democratic presidential candidates
support giving illegal immigrants free
health care at our expense is mostly
false but we have the video we have the
video from NBC News from the Democratic
presidential debate where the moderator
asks do you support giving health care
to illegal aliens and not just one not
just two every single candidates hand
wanna use your hand if covered if your
government plan would provide coverage
for undocumented
grunts so every hand goes up there how
does PolitiFact justify it they're
mostly false rating they say that the
moderators question did not specify if
the health care was free but it did it
actually did she said would your
government plan provide health care for
illegal immigrants provide the word
provide it's giving it's bringing it
it's giving it to them it is actually
even their BS trying to Clintonian sort
of twisting the words doesn't work it's
just an out-and-out lie that's from
PolitiFact no credibility the view no
credibility
all of these mainstream outlets just do
not command our respect and it makes you
think a little differently about the
president who's usually the object of
their ire even in the administration you
know we had been told all the really
smart people all the fancy people who
were jackets and ties and live in the
beltway they said look Trump might be
terrible
I'm not even about right-wingers I'll
say Trump might be terrible but at least
we have responsible people in the
administration good serious responsible
people defending the rule of law
defending our institutions and our norms
people like I don't know Rex Tillerson
former Secretary of State people like
John Calley former chief of staff
they're the good guys they're the one
defending our norms and our Constitution
Trump is the one destroying it except
now in a new book in a new interview
nikki Haley is saying that it was
actually guys like Tillerson and kelly
who were undermining our norms
undermining our institutions undermining
our constitution nikki Haley writes in
her new book quote Kelly and Tillerson
confided in me that when they resisted
the president they were not being
insubordinate they were trying to save
the country
here's nikki Haley Secretary of State
Taylor some went on to tell you the
reason he resisted the president's
decisions was because if he didn't
people would die you memorialized that
conversation it definitely happened
it absolutely happened and instead of
saying that to me they should have been
saying that to the president not asking
me to join them on their sidebar plan it
should have been go tell the president
what your differences are and quit if
you don't like what he's doing but to
undermine a president is really a very
dangerous thing and it goes against the
Constitution and it goes against what
the American people want and it was was
offensive that's right
that's absolutely right and this is
where I come this is where I begin when
I'm evaluating something the president
has done
I do not begin from the position the
Trump is always writing I love
everything he's doing whether that's on
policy whether that's um executive
action whether that's on his behavior
that's actually not where I begin and I
do have some policy problems with the
president for instance I didn't like the
first-step Act I thought that was a
mistake
I felt that health care could have been
handled a little differently sure so
there are some policy differences
however where I begin is from position
of assuming the the best of the
president and maybe the corruption of
the mainstream media why do I assume
that because that's exactly the opposite
of the scripts that I'm being told by
the mainstream media and I've just been
fooled one too many times the media have
told us the Trump colluded with Russia
to overturn the 2016 election that he
should be impeached for his tax problems
that he's a racist and a bigot and a
Nazi and a terrible person and they've
been lying the whole time and so I just
approach these questions not even with
treating these guys differently I won't
even say that I treat I begin assuming
Trump is really great in the media are
really terrible I just begin with a
little skepticism about those claims and
I give a little bit of grace to the
president because it's the opposite of
what we're getting and usually that
appears to be the right way to go you
can even see this with the extra
administration officials who have done
well the ones who have done well the
ones who positioned themselves well or
the ones who don't throw him under the
bus like nikki Haley or in this case
like Jeff Sessions so Jeff Sessions
former attorney general who actually did
sort of get done wrong by the
president I mean he was the subject of
many mean tweets from the president that
could have had one imagines been handled
behind closed doors Jeff Sessions has
not come and criticized the president
now he's running for his old Senate seat
what what's interesting about this is
not sessions wants to run for Senate I
thought for months that he would run for
Senate what's interesting about this is
that sessions is running for Senate not
against the president but on the
president's record here is the opening
ad of his would-be campaign the opening
ad doesn't even talk totally about his
record it talks about the president's
record he hears the ad and then he talks
about it - Tucker Carlson when I left
president Trump's cabinet did I write a
tell-all book no did I go on CNN and
attack the president nope have I said a
cross word about our president not one
time and I'll tell you one first that
would be dishonorable I was there to
serve his agenda not mine second the
president's doing a great job for
America and Alabama and he has my strong
support
he has your strong support do you have
his strong support well I hope so I
think he will respect my work I was
there for the Trump agenda every day I
was in the Senate no doubt about that
was the first Republican first senator
to endorse him yes we pushed his
immigration agenda his trade agenda and
began to work to a more realistic
foreign policy I love this answer the
president has my support okay well does
do you have the president's support yes
I hope I do but it's not about me
that's the subtext of what you have
sessions is saying because I hope I have
the president's support but my support
for the president is not simply some
kind of calculation to get him to help
me it's not a quid pro quo if you will
my support of the president is for what
the president is doing because not only
is it not about me it's not even really
about Trump it's about what Trump is
doing this is an important lesson for
all of us when people want to assail the
administration go after them on what
they're doing I mean go look we can have
a disagree
about something like the first-step Act
for instance but don't go after them for
yourself it's not about you it's not
look if you're serving the President as
chief of staff like John Kelly or
Secretary of State like Rex Tillerson if
you disagree with the president's agenda
then don't take the job there's no shame
in that if the president asks you to
serve and you say look I disagree with
what you want to do so I'm not gonna
serve ok fair enough
the worst thing you could do is go in
there and then undermine your own boss
and sabotage your own job that's making
it all about you and a lot of people are
doing that these days in politics not
just people working in the
administration but senators and
congressmen and even pundits and
rank-and-file voters they're making it
about them what is this what is this
commentary going to do for me or say
about me what is this time I serve in
the administration or and just do and
say for me me me what does this vote say
about me and how will it reflect on me
it's not about you that's so much of the
problem that we're seeing in the country
it's not about you we're living at a
time of intense political narcissism
egotism and pride we have a whole month
that celebrates pride we have a whole
internet structure now that exists to
gratify each of us individually to
accumulate likes to accumulate views to
sort of worship at the altar of the self
each and every one of us is the 2006
time Person of the Year because that
year it was you and we need to push back
against this and say hold on I'm willing
to subdue and restrain my ego and even
my own desires to accomplish something
outside myself to accomplish something
for the country that was the Jeff
Sessions argument that's the Jeff
Sessions argument going into the Senate
race and I think that's absolutely
terrific
now you
not just conservatives it's not just
wishful thinking I think that is saying
that Trump's looking pretty good
compared to his critics I'm always aware
of that I understand look I'm a
conservative I'm a Republican I I don't
want to just get trapped in a little
bubble but I don't think it's just us I
don't think it's just us who thinks
Trump is looking good right now I think
the Democrats are terrified the Trump is
looking good right now that's why even
in a field that had over 20 candidates
or 25 candidates there are more
Democratic candidates about to jump in
the race because they do not believe
that any of those Joker's on the stage
are gonna be done and Trump next
November we will get into which
candidates are running and which eternal
candidate still will not be able to give
it up I'm talking about the person who
totally didn't kill Jeffrey Epstein I'm
or I'm just because he killed himself so
I'm obviously I'm not or did he not
maybe he didn't kill himself well we'll
get to all of that in a second but first
I've got a second about a Facebook and
YouTube head on over to Daily wire comma
10 bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me get the
Andrew Klavan show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh so
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up on Thursday you get another
Kingdom the final end in my opinion
greatest season yet of a really
important story written by Andrew Clavin
and you get the leftist tears tumblr
this is the view edition it's really I
think it's really good for your voice
and helps you really elevate the
American discourse so head on over to
daily wire.com we'll be right back
we may have a new candidate in the
Democratic race I can't say we
officially have a new candidate yet
because there has not been a formal
announcement but this candidate has
officially filed paperwork to run in at
least the Alabama primary because there
was a campaign deadline and so this can
and it got in there early before that
deadline was over I'm not speaking about
Hillary Clinton we'll get to her in a
second I'm speaking about what what
obviously the Democrats want you know in
in 2019 intersectional Democrats
populism socialism obviously what the
Democrats are clamoring for is one of
the richest men in the world a
billionaire from New York Michael
Bloomberg Mike Bloomberg has been
signaling not just for weeks and months
but years that he wants to run for
president
he's been signaling that he wants to run
for president since the year 2000 and
he's never quite done it why not because
Mike Bloomberg who look I lived in New
York and Mike Bloomberg was Mayor Mike
Bloomberg ran for mayor of New York as a
Republican no one really thought he was
a Republican but he figured he'd have
the easiest time running as a Republican
he runs he wins he then quickly became
an independent then eventually he
registers as a Democrat so what are Mike
Bloomberg politics Mike Bloomberg is
what is often referred to as the fiscal
conservative social liberal and I think
even those terms are a little silly what
is it to be a fiscal conservative the
history of conservative philosophy
encompasses many economic ideas what
does it mean to be a social liberal what
what it basically means is that Mike
Bloomberg is a greedy Democrat that's
what it means to be a fiscal
conservative social liberal it means I
want to redefine marriage I want to have
policies that kill babies I want to
support legal infanticide I want people
to do whatever they want I don't care
that much about the culture or it
doesn't interest to me
I've got my pen ties up here I can live
whatever life I want and
you ruffians on the ground can fend for
yourselves but at the very least I want
to keep more of my money
greedy Democrats that's what it is and
this is not a popular position if you
live on the coasts if you ever go to
elite institutions if you ever go around
those nice cocktail parties in
Washington DC or New York or San
Francisco or Los Angeles you will very
often hear people say oh gosh look we
need to get over this abortion stuff we
need to legalize abortion forget about
any laws that in any way touch upon what
could reasonably be construed as
traditional morality but look I'm
reasonable I just want to lower taxes if
you could have a candidate who wanted to
lower taxes and liberalize all of our
social policy you would win the whole
country he'd get 90 percent of the vote
this is what all the coastal people
think this is what all the graduates of
fancy colleges think and they're
completely wrong you know they're
completely wrong because there have been
polls about this the people who
identifies fiscal conservative social
liberal the people who are Mike
Bloomberg in their politics constitute
about four-and-a-half percent of the
voting population four and a half
percent nobody nobody wants that and the
fancy people on the coasts who graduated
from Harvard don't understand how that's
possible the reason that they say the
reason that people don't identifies
fiscal conservatives and social liberals
is they're just not educated enough no
that's not the problem the reason that
they people don't identify as fiscal
conservatives and social liberals is it
doesn't make any sense conservative
thought has an internal logic to it if
you defend tradition if you defend our
institutions if you defend property
rights in the United States if you
defend these things they all sort of go
together on the flip side if you are a
radical if you hate our institutions if
you hate our system of government if you
hate our system of property rights if
you think is all rotten to the core
there is a sort of internal coherence of
leftism
what does not make sense is taking the
simplest most tempting most alluring and
most self-serving parts of each and
smashing them together saying well I'm a
complete degenerate on morality but I'm
also greedy let's put those together
that doesn't make sense it's alluring
and it's attractive but it doesn't make
any sense which is why I'm still
skeptical that Bloomberg will actually
throw his hat in the race not because he
doesn't want it not even because he's
cowardly but because he's got very good
pollsters he sees the numbers and it's
probably not going to work out very well
for him I mean just to give you an
example of the kind of moral blindness
of people like Mike Bloomberg listen to
an interview he gave just just this year
I believe with Margaret Hoover of the
new version of firing line in which Mike
Bloomberg explicitly defends the
communist government of China the United
States currently accounts for about 15%
of global greenhouse gas emissions China
accounts for roughly 30 percent of
greenhouse gas emissions how do we even
if we get to Net Zero and we're doing
our part how do you account and how do
you get China India and the other
countries China is doing a lot India's
doing some but I think that the China is
doing a lot yes they're still building a
bunch of coal-fired power plants yes
they are but they are now moving plants
away from the cities the Communist Party
wants to stay in power in China and they
listen to the public when the public
says I can't breathe the air
shaping is not a dictator he has to
satisfy his constituents so he's not
going to survive but it's not a dictator
no he has to he has a constituency to
answer to he doesn't have a democracy if
his advisers on him just a revolution
you're not gonna have a revolution
nobody's sick no government survives
without the will of the majority of its
people what so when Mike Lindbergh says
is look the dictator of China he's not
really a dictator he's accountable to
his people Margaret Hoover says how is
he accountable he doesn't have any
elections he doesn't have any
serious democratic mechanisms so are you
saying that the only way is accountable
is cuz there will be a revolution and
then Bloomberg admits he says oh there's
not going to be a revolution oh no that
guy's got an iron fist no way are you
gonna get a revolution in China so then
he's a dictator but Mike Bloomberg
doesn't want to say he's a dictator
because all Mike Bloomberg is concerned
with in this discussion is that we keep
that economic growth going we keep
boosting that GDP and we keep getting
those cheap Chinese goods and we keep
getting China to buy up our debt and we
keep getting China to be part of this
kind of liberal vision of one world
market with ever-increasing global
governance where national ties bonds of
loyalty don't really exist at all and
countries don't stand for anything other
than the relentless pursuit of economic
growth by the way I love economic growth
I think it's a great thing I think urban
crystal was largely right when he said
that the three pillars of modern
conservatism and it's ironic because
people who use the term neoconservatism
as a disparaging insult are usually
defining conservatism along the very
same lines as the neoconservative Irving
Kristol Irving Kristol said the three
pillars are religion economic growth and
nationalism and what Mike Bloomberg is
saying is yeah forget that religious
stuff forget that nationalist stuff
forget all that kind of cultural and
social stuff it's just about economic
growth look if you have enough economic
growth the dictators will be accountable
to the people I mean this was the line
we were told for decades and then
Margaret Hoover ask the question wait
doesn't look like he's accountable to
the people and Bloomberg more or less
admits yeah well gays not really that
accountable but look at the economic
growth that is not going to sell it's
not going to play in Peoria not because
the voters are so uneducated but because
the world view doesn't make sense and
because it is repugnant now we're
speaking of repugnance we might have
another candidate in the race our
favorite perennial candidate who spent a
lot of time in st. Petersburg when she
felt it was time for a change
Hillary Clinton was speaking at a New
York Times event and it's a live event
and she's asked
she's running again and of course she
can't say no because she's trying to
figure out the easiest way to jump back
into this race final question what would
it take you to run I'm sorry to run to
run you know I I have always been a very
very slow runner and you know I I am
embarrassingly slow I I've tried to run
races and I am so far behind that I
start to walk acting like that was what
the plan was all the time so I don't
know that I'm gonna take up competitive
running right now but I think you're
asking about something else aren't you
well there's been some teasing I'm some
muting that maybe that maybe you're
sitting in the in the off to the wings
here waiting for some moments oh you
know look I think I would have been a
really good president I think I could
have been a very I think I could have
done a really good job I think the last
election was deeply flawed and that
there were so many unprecedented
problems in that election that it's
almost hard to make sense of but you
know I'm out here traveling around with
my daughter and and she's still nursing
her newest baby so we've got our you
know I've got my grandson with me and
you know life is pretty good life is
pretty good and I'm totally not thinking
about running for president or anything
that's why I keep sending my senior
advisor on television to float the idea
that I could run for president she's so
bad at this it reminds me when when her
answer on this are you running what what
like running like like running a race hi
reminds me of that time she was asked
why she wiped her email server when the
federal government was asking for those
records and she just totally bleached
bidded the thing and she gave the same
answer where she was trying to be cute
and it totally fell flat that's all I
could say
you know I don't I have no idea that's
why we turned it over did you like this
what might with a cloth or something no
no I don't know how it works digitally
at all I do not have any and I know you
want to make a point and I can just
repeat what I have said what what did we
wipe it why what what a cloth or
something humma-nah humma-nah humma-nah
i don't know i don't know nothing i
don't know nothing it's Hillary
Clinton's answer same thing I'm running
cuz she does want to run again the point
I saw in all of this though is obviously
the Democrats feel that the field is
weak even though the field has just
about every candidate out there what is
it 20 25 candidates when they began they
feel that it's weak and for all their
bluster about impeachment Trump's gonna
go and she's a dead man walking they
don't think that and that's why other
candidates are thinking about getting
into this race they think that Joe Biden
is a totally weak frontrunner is
probably not going to get the nomination
they think Liz Warren is way too radical
to win a general election they feel the
same thing about Bernie plus you with
Bernie you also have the age issue they
think that he's falling apart and then
on the maybe more substantive matter the
ethical matter of the norms and the
trust in our institutions let's not
forget Hillary Clinton before the 2016
election said the people are gonna
accept the results of elections or a
threat to our democracy meanwhile now
we're three years after the election and
in that very same clip she's not
accepting the results of that election
she says there were so many problems
with it it was unprecedented it boggles
the mind what happened the the
implication here being that it was an
illegitimate election and she wants a
redo that's what they want and that's
what the president is up against and
that's the stakes of the election that's
the stakes of the political moment that
we're in the answer to this is not to
gloss over all the flaws of our own side
we certainly shouldn't do that but we
should be willing to see with clarity
the absolute rank corruption and
desiccation that we're up against and
then we have to make a choice and the
choice to me seems pretty clear and the
choice is not just a political choice it
can be a romantic choice as well ms my
favorite story out today
there is a new study out by the dating
app lumen which shows that conservatives
are much better at dating than liberals
this company found that right-wingers
are more direct than their left-wing
counterparts you know we're not that
kind of mealy-mouthed saying one thing
and meaning another and slippery and
unctuous and Whaley we're just we tell
people what we think that's what gets us
in trouble
on campus and our jobs and television
and in politics the company found that
they clearly state conservatives clearly
state to potential lovers what they're
looking for in terms of life and romance
and that they also value family and
friendships more highly than liberals do
and they have a smaller and more
intimate group of friends they're closer
whereas liberals tend to thrive in
larger social groups where they don't
really know anybody conservatives have
friends and intimates and liberals have
acquaintances the Liberals the advantage
they found for the Liberals in the study
is that liberals are more carefree and
more fun-loving than conservatives so
you know when liberals do get a date get
gets a little bit weird or I guess but
for the conservatives they care much
more about these relationships they're
more direct why is this it seems to me
it's the same issue we keep going back
to and going back to conservatives that
are best in our worldview in our
philosophy look away from ourselves we
look at the world we find great awe in
the world you know I forget if it was
Chesterton Louis who said that we're I
think was Chesterton who said we're
we're dying our culture is in trouble
not from lack of wonders but from lack
of wonder there's so many wonders in the
world people are so beautiful so
interesting and wonderful to talk to
people but what we're suffering from is
a lack of curiosity lack of awe from
ourselves to even be interested in those
other people it's the the same kind of
view of the sexual revolution you know
if you look at the consequences of the
sexual revolution ubiquitous high-speed
and pornography hookup culture all of it
the hook-up culture is ubiquitous now
too and many people have experienced
that especially in college but when you
look at the consequence
of that it's all essentially about the
self it's about me widespread abortion
on demand abortion itself is all about
you me me me at no regard whatsoever for
the other person who is killed as a
result of this all of it the
consequences of this for children that
awful case in Texas where the mother
wants to inject her son with hormones
and block him from going through puberty
because she really wants him to be a
daughter it's all about the self and
that is corrosive it makes people
unhappy it makes them bad dating
partners and it's why conservatives do
better in the dating scene but it turns
out that's not the last thing they
discover what we've also discovered is
that conservatives are hotter than
liberals science proves it according to
these studies a person's looks
apparently affect their politics and
beautiful people leaned more toward
conservative beliefs according to a
study published by two professors in the
Midwest if you control for
socio-economic status you find that more
attractive individuals are more likely
to report higher levels of political
efficacy identify as conservative and
identify as Republicans this makes sense
too it's not just a joke I mean I kind
of joke about it a little bit sometimes
that conservatives are hotter than
liberals but it does make sense because
conservatives tend to be more at peace
in the world
not that they're always happier but
they're more at peace they're more
understanding of reality and the reality
of suffering and the brokenness of human
nature and we're not constantly chasing
utopias and we're not constantly falling
apart and focusing on or suffering and
on ourselves as the center of the
universe because we know that isn't true
we're more at peace in the world and I'm
not surprised that people who have some
physical advantages also are more at
peace as well just a little nugget to
tuck away in there next time you're
arguing with your left-wing friends
before we go I have to I have to thank a
couple of heroes one is a cultural hero
a kid on MSNBC who was asked why he
supports Trump and he gave the best
answer I've ever heard
voted for the president 2016 there's
headquarters of his ydy him so much and
what policies stand out to you I would
say mainly just the no-nonsense policies
and especially since Jeffrey Epps we
didn't kill himself
yeah so what do you support Trump I just
think the policies are really good
especially because Jeffrey Epstein
didn't kill himself
total cultural hero well done also we
have to thank our very literal heroes
today our veterans we should thank
veterans every day but at least we have
a day for this the day originally it was
Armistice Day the 11th hour of the 11th
day of the 11th month of 1918 and then
this became in 1950 for Veterans Day
there's some confusion people treat
Memorial Day and Veterans Day as the
same holidays they're not Memorial days
for our servicemen who have fallen and
maybe ultimate sacrifice veterans days
for the veterans that we see all around
us unfortunately I think it's something
like just 1% of Americans have any
connection relate to the military serve
in the military and so it's harder and
harder to find them but when you do find
them today thank them for their service
thank them for defending this wonderful
country that we have keeping us all safe
and in defending the liberties that we
all enjoy and I certainly thank all of
the veterans who listen to this show
that's our show I'm Michael Nolt this is
the Michael Nolt show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike or Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
you